[Musique]
les prix risquent d'augmenter chez
dollarama au cours des prochains mois le
détaillant a présenté des résultats en
hausse à taux son deuxième trimestre
marie-claude mais ce qui a retenu quand
même la tension marie-claude ce sont
surtout des coûts de transport et une
marchandise
beaucoup beaucoup de questions des
analystes un gerald de ce matin sur les
coûts de transport la disponibilité de
la marchandise et combien ce que ça
coûtera la faire venir d'asie donc la
direction a expliqué que les tarifs à
court terme pour les prochains mois sont
déjà fixés et qu'elle est en
renégociation pour les contrats pour
l'an prochain les suivantes s'est faite
très discrète sur les conditions de ces
nouveaux contrats on n'a même pas voulu
dire quand exactement ils seraient
signés mais on s'attend à des hausses de
coûts on n'a juste pas voulu dire à quel
point ils pourraient être élevées c'est
ce qu'a dit la direction ce matin et
côté approvisionnement s'est montré
rassurant pour les items saisonniers
ceux de l'arwing sont déjà sur les
tablettes et ceux d'un noël parce que ça
s'en vient bientôt une période très
importante pour dollarama est bien sont
déjà dans les entrepôts alors pas
vraiment de risque pour les vendre
saisonnières s'établissent à quel point
l'ips riche et de la roma pourrait
alimenter marie-claude c'est dur à dire
il ya eu beaucoup de questions on
essayait d'avoir un peu détaillées mais
on dit que ça dépendra vraiment des
nouveaux contrats mais ce qu'on s'attend
sait qu'il faudra probablement augmenter
les prix si les hausses sont la nouvelle
normale on a dit la nouvelle normalité
ici c'est là pour rester un an ou deux
l'ensemble des prix sera augmentée elle
ce sera probablement le cas aussi chez
les concurrents d'ailleurs on a vraiment
senti une préoccupation de rester
concurrentiel on va bouger
si la concurrence bouche mais on
s'attend à ce que tous les détaillants
doivent augmenter leurs prix au cours
des prochains mois et on risque aussi
général de voir des prix des produits à
quatre de leurs ennemis 5 $ chez
dollarama la direction est assez
réticente a dit on en est en pole encore
on veut attendre le plus possible mais
on va peut-être devoir aller jusqu'à là
son voeu
préserver notre sélection de produits
sains pour pouvoir avoir tous les
produits qu'on veut sur les tablettes et
on a aussi en parallèle revue l'offre de
produits les on essaie d'avoir vraiment
des produits moins chers revoit par
exemple la quantité le poids est aussi
parfois certaines caractéristiques
utiliser des plastiques moins cher pour
peut-être économiser un peu et on dit
que les consommateurs normalement
devraient pas trop s'en rendre compte
alors on va chercher des petites
économies comme ça pour essayer
d'atténuer la hausse des coûts de
transport merci marie claude pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit